Speaker 1: Our voicemail number is 2192, David.
Here is a great voicemail from someone who
appreciates all of the debate coverage that
we have been doing this election season.
Speaker 4: David, Sara, this is Caitlyn from
Florida.
Thank you.
I just wanted to call to thank you for your
coverage of all of these debates.
I've really been enjoying your coverage.
I missed the Kansas Chris debate last night,
so I went to the gym and started your livestream
to listen to this morning.
And I was delighted to be surprised by your
new David Pakman and my Pillow remix.
Yes.
So there I was listening to the sound of that
song.
Speaker 1: Well, that is that is an absolutely
heartwarming thing to hear.
Two things on this one.
We have streamed probably a dozen different
debates so far this election season.
One of the most interesting ones is tonight,
Mehmet Oz versus John Fetterman.
I hope you'll join me at 7:30 p.m. Eastern
on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook.
And secondly, yes, Chris Barrios putting together
one of the best remixes ever of anything we
have done.
Listen to just a little bit of this masterpiece,
worried about my espresso machine.
I'm like, Oh, that could be your headline.
It's not a joke.
It's just I'm worried.
But my always.
Speaker 5: Off there like an around it up
just below.
Speaker 3: My computer on the back and chatter
just exploded.
I'm trying.
I'm getting rid of the machines melting down.
Turn them into prison bars here.
I'm not.
Speaker 1: Okay.
You get the point anyway.
Remixes, debates, all of it.
Join me tonight at 7:30 p.m. Eastern Oz versus
Fetterman.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about the new British prime minister,
Rishi Sunak.
We will talk about Mark Hamill, by the way,
a fan of The David Pakman Show founder The
David Pakman Show Mark Hamill, sending 500
drones to Ukraine.
And we will talk about Adidas or as some call
it, Adidas, cutting ties with Kanye West after
the antisemitism explosion.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Sign up at Joining Politics.